why don't you like chandler what's your
deal with chandler
i want you to challenge my guy watching
oh we've got so many just inside stuff
man
like inside stuff i mean you know guys
right now
no no not to you brought to you
what's your deal with no it just comes
down to like the guys that always have
the
you know the tattoos that say blessed on
their chest or some sort of god
like thing on their body there's only
two guys him and john yeah whatever they
they're you know they're just not the
most real of real
very i know personally firsthand he's
very fake
he's just fake remember remember how dc
and in jon jones i look i can't speak on
jon jones but i remember how dc and john
jones got in the espn thing when the
camera started off i was like yeah
[ __ ] kill yeah i'd kill you yeah
that's [ __ ] right yeah
you saw the real jon jones yeah you saw
dc yep you know what i mean
dc has always been and that and that's
the that's the michael chandler portion
of the part that i've seen so
it's been that way out of [ __ ] with him
at all he like turns off
yeah he turns off the do you think he's
fake very fake
that's my personal opinion man but
that's me with him and i've seen him
around
just my opinion i've that's just my own
like if people think otherwise
hey i'm cool i have no experience yeah
yeah my experience with him
it's fake and then look and every people
that people that i know are good people
like
benson henderson friends everything like
that
until the fight thing came up and then
it was like big and dance is like
he's the biggest fakest [ __ ]
i've ever met interesting and benson's
like one of those guys he loves
everybody yeah he's such a
he's such a [ __ ] great guy i don't
care what you people think of his
fighting style
you know all that stuff he's a [ __ ]
great guy a person you know and so when
someone like that comes on and just
backed up what i said i'm like
i get it man you know you gotta remember
why you had an issue yeah just it's my
own personal stuff with him there's
other stuff
behind the scenes i don't want to get
into because it's personal but i get
what you're saying man